he is MLB chief baseball officer
four-time World Series champ nine-time
all-star want a batting championship and
had his number retired by the Yankees
he's Joe Torre back on the show Good
Morning Joe how are you it's been a
while Dan I thought you forgot all about
me no we can't forget about you and I'm
sure this weekend there were a lot of
memories that came to mind and you know
maybe or sometimes they refreshed in
your memory with Mariano and Mike
Mussina we just had Mariano on and he's
really in a down mood Joe Meaux is he's
still a little bit upset that you didn't
allow him to play at least one at-bat in
centerfield defensively for one batter
did you ever consider that no I just
missed it right away then I can just see
him because he's so competitive you know
that hat that batter would hit the ball
to left center or right centerfield and
areas jumping against the wall and
making a great catch and laying there
and having a stretcher take him off the
field so no thanks
I was I was satisfied with with the two
or three or four or five innings he'd
pitch to help us win a ballgame when did
you know you had something I think it
was in 96 again going spring training
obviously I didn't know what we had I
know we ought to pitch her that had no
options left and that we had to keep him
on the roster and we had Bob Wickman and
and John wetland as other closers so he
didn't you know he was more of a starter
in the minor leagues but we discovered
her early on he brought him into a game
in the sixth in APIs that said I'm in
the seventh and eighth plus the seventh
in the eighth and you know wetland would
tie it up in the ninth and you know it
certainly it certainly made for easy
managing because you're only in a matter
of six innings and so that combination
you know made it happen and you know
when it came time for the end of the our
season we win the World Series
was the MVP knowing what Mariano had
done it really wasn't a tough call to
you know the time as the closer go back
to what you were saying about Mariano he
was out of options so this was sort of
the last chance you had to keep him on
the roster was there a chance that he
wasn't that you were gonna trade him
well you know there was a rumor I don't
go very far it makes for a good story
and a lot of it was was really circling
around Jeter who didn't have a
particularly good spring and there was
talk at the end of spring training I
mean in the end it was probably the last
week or so that we'd send Jeter down in
the minor leagues and then maybe used
Mariano to get a shortstop but it it was
just you know maybe one conversation
didn't go very far and you know thank
goodness for you know all of us that it
didn't go very far but you know it was
pretty much that we're gonna have to you
know make room for him because of his
arm and you know he showed us he showed
me anyway when I was watching that game
against Seattle that looked like you had
pretty good poise on the mound in a very
tight situation out there and you know
obviously he didn't disappoint anybody
did you how many times did you take
Rivera out of a game when he was closing
just just Horne when he got beat up a
little bit I was disappointed I was the
only time I was disappointed with our
fans but they booed him coming off the
field he gave up some runs against
Boston and couldn't close it this was
the middle early or wasn't postseason or
anything but that way that was about it
I you know certainly once he once he
came into the game Dan I might I put my
hands in my pond I really had nothing
else to do or than a fee a spectator the
only one of course we were close to was
in 2003 when we felt you know enough was
enough we don't want to hurt this guy
and you know he wasn't gonna listen to
it he was going to go out there look
was decided talking to Joe Torre the
former major league manager now working
for major league baseball their chief
baseball officer there was a story that
Mike Mussina looked at you and said
don't even think about coming out to the
mountain is that true yeah no I got I
got it you know a man of few words
and you know when a pitcher does that
I'll turn around I'm making a bad face
and again it's not like a young kid you
know this is an experienced guy I always
I always listen to the veterans because
you know they know how they felt they
know what needed to be done so it didn't
happen very often obviously you know I
dig Andy Panik was probably mad at me
for a short period of time and every
time I took him out of that I decide
from that that was a very unusual for
Mike and I had no problem making about
about facial change in my life
Jeter is I believe eligible next year
why would you think that he wouldn't get
100% I expect Derek to be on everybody's
ballot next year I mean I wouldn't think
of a reason why he wouldn't be because
he was so respected around baseball and
and he was such a special special player
you know more so more more than just
ability and you know it's character in
the way he conducted himself and the
fact that he played so well under
pressure I you know again at high
expectations to say I bet you'll get on
2% but you know I don't expect it to be
anything definite that Mariano that I
didn't realize you never played in the
postseason as a player never did came
close a couple of times with st. Louis
and only the cups
I guess we're contending one slipped
with the Mets and that was in 73 when
they wind up going to the World Series
and
I think it was two years in a row we had
two another one here we had to wait for
the master plate that will hit her
against the Cubs at the end of the year
after the season was over and to
determine if we are you know we had
another opportunity to get there two
postseason but they won the first game
of the doubleheader and the second game
was called office it wasn't necessary
and we lost out but yeah two years in a
row we we got to the last few days and
we come up short I saw where the
Commissioner had some comments about the
safety netting netting and not every
stadium obviously is built the same when
do you think fans should expect safety
netting and all ballparks well you know
why that's it's really up to each
individual club you know we can only
suggest that you know for the safety of
the fans and a lot of they've been a
number of fans that have been resistant
to it because they feel like it's going
to you know steal foul ball from you
know from getting getting to them where
they can get us over there but you know
the safety factor I know and in Japan
they have it all the way down to follow
lines you know especially nowadays with
the social media and everybody looking
down at their phones and and stuff I it
just concerns me and you know we were
this young girl who you know got that
hip this year it it was it's so scary it
really is because even without the net I
mean you know even if you're sitting far
out you know even those balls hard it
it's really tough to get out of the way
the Robo umpires in the Atlantic League
certainly getting some attention when
how closely is Major League Baseball
monitoring these robotic umpires well
you know we we test a lot of stuff and
you know again we just did it starting
at the all-star break and we'll see you
at the electron
strike zone looks like a you know I'm
you know being the old girl I am I sort
of like the game to stay human and
that's you know essentially put replay
and and I think everybody expects to get
everything man and I don't think I don't
think that game is that way I think our
game is you know to me it's an imperfect
game and always felt perfect to me
because it was my my life like that from
a kid growing up either to the present
time and I'd hate to see us you know try
to be too perfect because there's not a
player out there that's perfect not a
pitcher out there is perfect and you
know I don't think the game is that way
but again you know when technology gets
to the point where did would replay
where we felt that it's unless we did
replay we'd have too much attention paid
to the to the call that was missed and
the game could have been turned on that
call and it takes the attention away
from the field so I I don't see the
robotic strike zone happening but again
I wasn't really into changing the slide
rule either but you know once you get
letters from from parents who kept it in
the minor leagues that were carried off
you have to give it a second thought I
have a guy who works with me his name is
McLovin and he's a he's a baseball guy
he's an analytics guy and he says that
basically the baseball manager is the
most overrated position in all the
sports and anybody could be a baseball
manager in the major leagues
McLovin is there anything else you'd
like I did not say that I just said the
trend you said you said that yesterday
now I think I'd go Tory then you don't
want to step up to the plate feel like
I'm at home now you guys are still like
okay do you want to see there's that
Moneyball trend that the manager has
been de-emphasized for the analytics
front office guys that's that's
happening it seems do you want to
respond to it it is happening and I'm
not a fan of it
I mean I information is important but
you know once we minimize the effect of
a manager and being able to look into a
guy's eyes and using the the instincts
that he gained in his years of baseball
I think is a big mistake I think we're
you know we can't make this a video game
and as I say that that's anti human
again when we do the numbers you know
you you know we had a three nothing lead
against the Red Sox and you know I guess
we could have called in the dogs at that
point cuz it wasn't supposed to happen
it never happened before but it did
happen and it's it's just something
about human beings playing the game that
make you scratch your head sometimes and
other times just you know surprised the
heck out of you in a good way so I you
know I I think we've gone a little bit
too far right now and the government is
right because I think they've they've
relied too much on numbers especially
with the whole pitching stuff of what's
going on now but you know we'll have to
wait and see I think the game of
baseball has been too good for too long
to to not survive this wait you just
said McLovin was right oh my god she's
gonna be insufferable I told you he was
brilliant yeah you got McLovin on your
side before I let you go you're doing
something great safe at home golf
tournament and that'll be held tomorrow
Sleepy Hollow Country Club in
Westchester County but tell people about
safe at home and you know how long
you've been involved in this Joe well
you know it's interesting Dan I grew up
my dad abused my mom I was a very shy
kid nervous kid wasn't until I got
myself a little counseling sauna by
mistake that I went to a seminar why
valleys will hew without daughter and I
found out that a lot of the sinners I
had to stop or what caused by what dad
was you know bringing to the house and
bringing home made everybody nervous I'm
the youngest of five so I really felt
free to talk about what I went through
as a child and it was my wife Alan and a
daughter my daughter Christina who
wanted to do it through education so we
could safe rooms and schools but NASA's
Global counselors and we give these kids
who deal with abuse at home or around
their big day great stuff like that I
mean it
we give middle school and high school
kids the ability to talk about it we
don't know it's not their fault
they're not alone and that the only one
when I was grown up in that home I
wouldn't share with any of my friends
because I didn't think anybody else
would understand that because I thought
we were the only ones but it's out there
and it's real and we've we've had close
to 100,000 kids come through our program
since we started you know - and actually
all five we started our first Margaret's
place it's the safe room we named after
my mom so you know tomorrow we're going
out there and we have a lot of
celebrities that come out we have MRSA
talking about a couple of pros Martha
Taos qilin Matthysse Jim Leyritz Jimmy
Leyland dan please act we even have Rudy
Ruettiger out there and former
newscaster Harvey Smith and from from
Hamilton Chris Jackson it's going to be
a fun day now the weather looks good
with you about fingers crossed and
hopefully you can raise some money for
our foundation anybody information story
organ it would be a little background on
what we do it's great to catch up with
you Joe hope the family's good and have
fun tomorrow
Thanks famine low that's a Joe Torre the
annual safe at home golf tournament held
tomorrow Joe Torre org for more
information on this and you know the
last couple of times Joe's been on he's
talked about this and you know to get to
the point where you can talk about this
and that's what he said he needed
therapy to get to that point but then to
then take it a step further to do what
he's doing safe at home and these safe
rooms and 100,000 kids have gone through
this so well done well done by Joe for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]